Adam Graham was a predator who abused
vulnerable women a double rapist who
attacked victims in their own homes and
this is the same person now known as
Isla Bryson a transition made after they
were arrested court today the sex
offender jailed for eight years
you see yourself as the victim in this
situation
you are not it is plain that you present
a particularly significant risk to any
woman with whom you form a relationship
Bryson will spend their sentence in this
male prison after our erupted when they
were initially sent to Scotland's only
all-female jail
this is a case with huge ramifications
Way Beyond the courtroom itself it
became the center of political and
social conversation at a time when
gender reforms here in Scotland were
under scrutiny it led to embarrassment
for ministers it triggered change on how
transgender prisoners are dealt with and
arguably it led to this sudden demise of
Nicholas sturgeon as first Minister I am
trying to rationally individually what
I'm trying to do is address the issues
it led to awkward questions floundering
from a first Minister famous for her
robust communication skills and left
many wondering whether it did play a
part on the day of her resignation do
you believe though that the issues are
and particularly the right around
transgender prisoners was the straw that
broke the camel's back here no that
issue wasn't the final straw her
opponents have seized this as a moment
of political weakness I've got no doubt
whatsoever that this case and the whole
issue around this case is played a large
part in nickel surgeon's decision to
leave office
this was the case of one dangerous
rapist in one Community but the Fallout
caused political issues at the heart of
government and generated a national
conversation about gender Conor Gillis
Sky News Edinburgh